and now Brandon
sugar Sean what's going on brother The
Talk of the Town even though you didn't
fight you are the
there's I mean across all facets of
media right now in the fight game you
are the face of the bantamweight
division my man
yeah I mean I feel like I've been to
face the division for for a while now
but especially right now
um
duckstral Joe kind of you know hey give
give the guys credit just be Henry
sahuto but you know yeah we're kind of
outshining him with with uh you know the
sugar show against the title shot next
yeah the sugar show is here I mean it
arrived way before this but after the
Peter Yan win the solidifier is the
number one Contender kind of did it yeah
isn't it interesting because and I don't
get it without you you know I enjoy Al
Joe you know I love aljo he's a good
Fighter
um really the hate he just never gets
the respect it kind of it's just the
perfect storm for him I don't think you
know he didn't go into the Peter John
fights with a huge kind of following in
the Peter Yan the way he got the belt
right so it's like just people kind of
disrespect the dude and then even with
you know what he did to Corey Santa
Hagan's ridiculous TJ Dillashaw they're
like yeah but he was injured so he
doesn't get the credit there and then
with Henry cejudo they're like ah it's
an older sahuto he took three years off
I'm like damn well maybe the the sugar
fight is what he needs to get respect
even if he were to lose you're a monster
you would think that would give him the
respect I don't know what there's
certain guys there's just you know with
the UFC trying to figure out the
marketing there's not much you can do
man you know either you gotta you don't
yeah I don't and it's weird because it's
not like people they I think he went
through a phase where people definitely
didn't like him he hated it out a little
bit but he's never been super loved and
I would say it doesn't seem like he's
hated necessarily anymore he went
through that clown phase where people
are clown clown clown where I think that
kind of stopped so it's not really like
he's almost you know you almost got to
dive into that he'll heel more and just
be that guy that you know people want to
hate rather than try to be the guy that
people want to like they either like you
or they don't doesn't really matter what
you do what podcast you're going what
you say like you or they don't so yeah
he's kind of in that middle ground to
where he's like not hated not loved it's
uh you know weird I wouldn't want to be
in that position I want to be hated or
loved uh I'd Rather Be Loved I mean but
if you're from hated I'll [__] run
with that too yeah that you you want
them to have opinion one way or the
other you don't want to be neutral if
you look at the Floyd Mayweather kind of
blueprint people hated him and they
tuned into his fights some of the you
know the top four pay-per-views of all
time they tuned into his fights to see
him lose he don't care money's money
whether you pay it you level you pay it
you hate him all he cares about is the
money
ran with a little bit he was you know
the cringy thing he just leaned into it
so then some some people you know that
wasn't it
him and his little him and his coach
Captain like that's just not it and I
mean I think you can see yeah yeah I
mean that wasn't it I don't think uh he
tried you got to give him credit if he
tried and he's still trying and it's
still not working but uh who knows maybe
you just try for you know 10 15 years of
not working and who knows maybe it'll
randomly come along
yeah I think uh yeah now you were a guy
that came out I saw you scored it for
sehudo did you re-watch it were you high
do you because my producer out of like I
watched it with Dominic Cruz you know
you want to watch that 135 title shot
with a freaking goat that's Dominic Cruz
we both had it for Sterling pretty
easily four to one I could see three to
two yeah I could see three to two
argument three to two all entertain
outside that I don't see it now my
producer chin he his bad Vision his
glasses were dirty his glasses were
super dirty but when I heard you say you
thought so who don't want I didn't put
too much into it because I'm like well
he's saying cage side it's tough to
score fights cage side
yeah it was really hard to see like when
there's a pole in the middle and you're
missing out on you know a very important
parts or did that land or did that what
happened there it's hard to judge if I
um I also was maybe leaning towards
Hendrix I wanted him to win I wanted
that fight more I feel like I just
really you know want to slap Henry
um so that that's a fight in the future
that could still happen but watching it
Kate said I did think and I was honestly
a little surprised they gave to algerman
I thought in the wrestling the grappling
Department it was very neutral I didn't
really see at least from my perspective
no one really out grappled each other
too much and and on the feet it looked
like Henry was Landing the bigger shot
but I haven't watched it I really really
do want to watch it Tim and I are going
to watch it uh very soon to kind of you
know game plan for aljo anyway yeah but
uh I'm very interested in what what I'll
see and how that'll change because you
know a lot of people said there are
certain people I've talked to that said
watch it live had already rewatched it
and I did switch over to aljo so it it's
crazy like how how fights are just
different perspectives but yeah I'm
gonna re-watch it very soon and who
knows I might have a different uh
outlook on it here's the thing dude you
know how you've been a million fights
you've been you know okay side that's
the view of the judges it's like they
should not be cage side they should be
in a separate room where they can see
what the viewer seeing on TV because
that's the best way to critique a fight
analyze a fight being k-sider in person
is not the way to do it man
yeah no I mean that's a good point I
didn't think about that they probably
have a little bit better they put off
the poles in the way but still I mean
still the TV is the best way to watch a
fight the different angles that that for
sure the judges should be you know I
mean what do you think the judges in a
separate room with no audio or with just
just like the fight sound on it not the
crowd it's hard to you know I don't know
if that's possible but yeah I wonder
wonder what the most positive best way
to for the judges to watch him judge the
fight agree uh before we get into
fighting this just hit me then we get
back to sahuda and aljo and all that
other crap but dude your sons are
playing my nuggets
your sons are playing my nuggets and my
nuggets are beating that ass we're about
to close it out I think I think they
play on Friday we're gonna seal the deal
are you sad about that do you want to
bet on it what are you feeling here
you know what I I don't I don't keep up
with basketball enough I do know the
only reason I do is because I've been uh
playing price picks not the only reason
I kind of keep up with sports is when
I'm putting money on it and uh yeah I've
seen that the signs you know that day
it's not over it's not over until it's
over you know what I mean
2023 hey I think yeah I'm champ this
year Sons champ that could be pretty
crazy uh I'll be champ regardless this
year so maybe if they need to do you
know run it next year we can do it but
hey it's not over till it's over they
need to get your ass in there and give
them a freaking pep talk that's what
they need to do
or a [__] shooting guard wanted to I
don't want a shooting guard get in there
man Chris Falls first uh but let's get
back to the fight talk brother with the
fight talk you know when it you said you
uh were leaning towards the Hooda you
wants who to win I assume because you
think sahudo's gonna sell more
pay-per-views like it's a bigger fight I
feel like aljo after winning that the
bigger fight now I also before you
answer I don't think it matters I think
you're the cash cow here either way I
don't think it really matters on your
opponent
yeah I I agree at this point I'm like
well Alex would just beat Henry so so
it's they're very similar as far as sell
selling pay-per-views go
um but yeah I thought Henry or there's I
would like to slap Henry more than aljo
um I do think that stylistically Henry's
an easier fight for me not that aldra's
an easy fight by any means but I do
think you know he's a lot less dangerous
I'll just I'll just you know I I was one
of the greatest dancing weights of all
time yep uh with his resume right now
and current fighting is just different
than back in the day so I think aljo is
the best bantamweight
um right now so me going out there and
beating him will be massive will be huge
uh but yeah I thought Henry versus sugar
you know about all the Mexican Champs
what would be interesting but this would
be good still but also look at when you
when you look at Henry's skill set if he
fought you the way fought aljo that kind
of weird like taekwondo like straight up
stance man that'd be a tough night
that is that's exactly what I thought
when I saw him like boy if he gets past
Al Joe he fights you know sugar this way
that's gonna be a tough night with that
straight up chin in the air style and
hands like [__] bass rooting like
it's 1993. I was like dude this can be
tough
yeah that was weird I mean Connor Connor
posted a video that was pretty you know
pretty fun it was hilarious it was
accurate like what are you doing
standing like that you're 5'3 you fight
like it don't fight like you're agree I
mean that's not even a way to fight even
if you're tall with your chin up like
that hands like that don't go out there
making breakdowns saying you know the
greatest coach of all time the greatest
fighter of all time they go out there
with a whack-ass dance like that
um he's lucky he's lucky lost to aljo
because if he didn't lose algebra he
would have lost to me in a way worse
fashion I would have put his lights out
I agree with that
but I think aljo too he's not he wasn't
looking much sharper on the feet that
motherfucker's chins up there too and
walking for it all weird like he's gonna
get sniped I think you have a sizable
Advantage when it comes to striking over
both both of those guys like that that's
you know that's your huge advantage over
both these contenders even with Murad
you know I'm not contenders because
Sterling's a champ but with murab uh
Henry uh Sterling is the champ you have
a pretty huge Advance when it comes to
the Striking I mean all those guys and
then obviously we would give them more
of the advantage that comes to the
grappling that's why I'm excited to see
this because I think even your striking
was underrated until you fought Peter
yawn they'll be like oh damn it's like
yeah dude that's what most of all the
experts like Yeah The Kicking [__]
can box get that striking man yeah so I
think that Peter young kind of proved
those haters you know wrong
yeah I mean I dropped Peter I don't know
anyone else I just dropped Peter in the
second round I cracked my left hand I
did put him down with that right hand
shortly about briefly and that just goes
to show you how good Peter yawn was
because he hit me with a left hand that
I still don't know how I ate
um but uh yeah that Peter Yan is very
very dangerous I think he's way more of
a dangerous opponent than Henry I don't
know if he's necessarily more dangerous
Al Joe's dangerous in different ways
than Peter
um but I think Peter I think Peter beats
Henry for sure I think Henry I think
Peter sleeps Henry what's weird too is
after you what you did to Peter he's
never I think you mentioned this and I I
co-signed this on on my show Peter
hasn't been the same since that last
year he's never you know they're just
certain fights there's certain uh JDS
Depot JDS was never the same neither was
Stipe for that matter but there's
certain fights uh gustafin Jon Jones
there's certain fights guys are just
never the same
is very very dangerous and good in the
opposite way of me where he's just like
grapple Grandpa Grandpa grapple grapple
he fought a killer and morale it was
very dangerous so we'll see who Peter
gets next I think Peter versus Cheeto is
an interesting by Peter versus Henry is
an interesting fight uh Peter versus Rob
font like there's some big fights out
there that I'd like to see Peter you
know come back and I think he will but
also it's like
people hate losing to me because of you
know the way I look the way I talked
whatever it is they do not want to lose
to me especially after you know going
you know Peter I think that that was
going to be an easy fight we took him in
the Deep Waters and we beat him there so
I think uh yeah I mean that's gotta play
play some part in his mind yeah I think
you're one of those guys that falls in
that lane where it's like gosh you have
this huge following and people like oh
well he's more famous than he is
talented you know he's he's yeah really
famous he's big on you know all the
social media platforms he's big on you
know the video game scene and he has his
fan base but he's not he doesn't have
the skill like these other guys then you
get Peter Young they're like watch this
and then you whoop his ass like oh God
damn so I you're kind of the first guy
because I would say different obviously
the looks are completely different he's
across the pond but Patty pimlet similar
Vibe uh Vibe meaning his
how do I put this this is no disrespect
on Patty pimlin he doesn't have your
skill set he's just he's not there yet
but his Fame outshines his talent right
now so people are like oh we want to see
him against you know the number five guy
put him in there against you know gaichi
like Jesus Christ dude you know so it
can be a disservice and then the fan
base kind of revolt against that because
you haven't beat those guys to deserve
that place on the card but you're the
outlier who's done it when he beat Peter
Young
yeah yeah and that Peter Young fight
I've watched it so many times it is such
a close fight I do believe I won round
one and three but I'm I'm not mad at
people that say Hey you lost that fight
so hey that was a close fight Peter
Young I know how gangster that dude is
he is you know regardless of his last
fight against bro that dude is very very
dangerous was very tough fight so for me
to go out there and get the job done I
was like that was massive especially to
the fans the casuals that did think I
was just like you know big big following
it's like I got famous because I started
knocking people out I wasn't famous when
I came to the UFC we're not famous for
knocking people out I got famous because
I have
skills so uh yeah they're they're
different there and I agree with Patty
the Patty situation it's like
I don't know him personally I don't know
you know how I don't know his lifestyle
on his routines but for me I can say I
live this [__] I've lived this [__]
since I was you know 18 and moved to
Phoenix I train and I recover and that's
what I do
um you know yeah I smoke weed yeah I can
party with the boys sometimes but you
know that's a very very small percentage
of what I what I do I'm uh you know I
live this lifestyle yeah I think it's
different but I also think too for Patty
it's like you know massive massive
falling over there in Liverpool across
the pond there you know fighting those
uh was it cage of Fury or whatever the
hell it is cage Warriors massive you
know Champion cage Wars selling out
Arenas selling out more tickets than the
UFC did over there so he had this
massive following but I think the UFC
did right by you you know Dana White
Contender series you burst on the scene
and then they didn't just throw you to
the wolves like Sage Northcutt or
something like that like you had a great
progression and if I'm the UFC that
that's how it should be done man it's
the the MMA fan-based UFC fan base and
the matchmakers for a long time which is
toss you guys to the [__] Wolverines
and you know I did with sage with Patty
a little bit they taught some a little
bit too much too soon in his last fight
which we saw which most people think he
lost that fight so it just puts pressure
on the guy and a lot of it's from the
fans like no let these guys build up
like boxing does boxers don't fight
anybody to what [__] their 30th fight
or some [__] like that you know but
you've done it right man you and P if
I'm Patty I'm going I want the sugar
treatment like don't toss me the top 15
let me let me get my experience get in
the hot gun you can put me wherever you
want on the card but don't cost me these
[__] monsters like you've done it
right man
yeah I mean I think I I got the UFC when
I was like 22 years old I was so young
like I had only really been fighting
like at a good high level since I was
18. you know it's not not too long when
I got UFC and yeah they did UFC did a
really good job you know you got to give
props to Sean Shelby he's Shawn so he's
a brilliant dude
he does a really good job and uh yes you
know people hated it hate it or whatever
we're here now we're fighting for the
title I just beat a legitimate you know
a very legitimate guy that you can't
deny as very good skills uh former champ
former world champion and uh yeah so so
USC did a really good job
um but also yeah when you're in the UFC
maybe maybe maybe you don't get into the
UFC until you built that resume outside
the UFC or got skilled enough I I lucked
out and had I mean I can't take credit
for it UFC did a good job you know
building building my uh my resume and
and uh yeah we're here yeah here you are
man and when you look at I don't you
probably didn't see it but
when we had Diamond Cruz on the fight
campaign he's talking about the fight
and uh you know he obviously
he he he gives credit to Al John he
gives credit to Henry sahuda what are
you saying about so who do you don't
respect him taking the three years off
he goes it he goes just [__] [__] man
he goes well me the rest Contender is
like Suga and TJ and all of us are
working ass off fighting staying in Camp
you know we're getting tested all the
time he just quit for no reason yeah
he's like he had no reason he's like
he's just [__] [__] man he's like I
don't respect him taking three years off
healing his body and then deciding to
come back he's like that's not how this
game works he's like I just don't
respect it
it's an interesting perspective uh I
mean who knows you know he went out
there got a got a second girlfriend got
her pregnant had a baby took some
personal time I to me I'm on my own [__]
I don't give a [__] about anybody else
or what they're doing if they're taking
time off if they're taking fights at the
training I really just don't care I know
I'm training I know I'm improving and
getting better so yeah I wasn't mad
about it you know Henry he was the
double champ Olympic silver medalist I
mean I don't know the grace all-time
yeah
you know Hannah are you going to hear
that
uh uh yeah I don't to me I don't yeah I
don't care if it took three years off
I'm not worried about it yep and when
you look when if you when you really
watch that fight you'll see it you know
what Sterling does do well and I haven't
seen a lot of guys do this when he when
he tried it when he's on the ground he's
on all fours so make sure three points
of contact on the ground so he can't
throw the legal needs and if you do
you're gonna get disqualified so when
it's down there I don't see that being
an issue in your guys's fight you know
who knows maybe you decide to [__]
grapple all of a sudden but he he does
do a good job of kind of baiting those
illegal needs it's a weird and very
successful kind of uh thing that he does
yeah I think too I mean he's just he's
the type of guy that doesn't want to go
out there and get in a slug Fest which I
I get it I don't technically really want
to I'd rather me be the one piecing
someone up and he just really doesn't
want to get hit he doesn't have a
problem shooting he knows the rule set
and uh you can't meet someone when your
head's down like that he and he and he
knows that so it kind of you know he's
all right he wants the grapple I'm sure
we're going to be in that front headlock
position I might throw it illegal me
just for fun
why not we'll see how it goes why not
what's up bro I'm getting my ass kicked
okay
I'm sure we'll be in that position I'm
expecting you know ideally my plan go
out there not let him grab me that's you
know and and piece him up from the
outside his goal is going to be grapple
grapple grapple grab a hold of me and
I'll call and it's going down uh what
did Dana mentioned August in Boston
properly there
August 19th in Boston is kind of what
we're thinking uh that's what I'm
planning for I'm gonna slowly start
getting into Camp we're 14 weeks out
which is I mean 14 and a half damn near
15 weeks out pretty much four months you
know people are like oh that's too quick
of a turnaround no not really you know
he doesn't have any serious injuries you
know he has plenty of time take a couple
months off two months training camp
that's plenty uh so yeah I I don't think
that's too fast of a turnout I think
that'll be perfect especially he wants
to go up to 45 I'll send his ass up to
45 he go fight back on the prelims yeah
the only the only thing that would be
kind of when people say oh it's too uh
quick of a turnaround would be the
weight cut you know because it does cut
a lot of weight that'd be the only kind
of hick up there but if he just stays
you know it doesn't go too crazy stays
professional and knows that this has
happened on August he should be all
right Sterling's professional
there's a lot it's not that fast so
that's a good amount of time to you know
yeah don't get fat just stay you know
just stay some of this one you're the
bad point Champion uh the best fighter
in the world
to be able to come to cut weight again
that fast shouldn't be that big of a
deal agree brother and he's talking
about after this one going to 145 well I
think win or loss he's going to go to
145. let's say you take care of business
right you piece this dude up no illegal
needs like we're talking about for you
at for you at 135 you know you got morob
you got you got some pretty good
contenders are you looking obviously
we're not looking past Sterling but is
that who you kind of thinking next morob
especially after the whole jacket thing
stuff like that kind of create a little
bit of hype
yeah after I'll draw I definitely you
know I plan on sticking around 35 for a
while 45 definitely in in the future but
I would like to defend about the 35 like
you said we're not looking past algor I
understand how big of a test and how you
know difficult of a fight this could be
but I also know that I can put his
lights out the way he marches forward as
far as who would be next
um it kind of depends you know I I want
that Cheeto rematch back I think that's
probably but I know he's coming off a
loss so he'd have to go out there and
get and get a win which is very yeah he
could do that Corey you know people
think that's a that's a big fight it's
kind of a big fight Corey's probably
like the worst guy at promoting himself
or at uh you know getting any interest
in fights so you know that that's still
there
um Corey morabs yeah definitely there's
already you know a little story behind
that one especially being Al Jos uh
friend uh who else is up there
um
I mean when you go through the list
what'd you say
Rob thought just had a beautiful
performance over Adrian John has that
yeah that's amazing yeah yeah so there's
a lot of possibilities I truly believe
me versus any of those guys is a massive
fight just because uh I I feel like you
know people want to see me win some
people want to see me lose I do think I
have more of the destiny win fans I'm
curious what these odds will be when
aljo comes out army versus aljo with Oz
uh I I think it's like someone came out
with him we're talking about a Monday
show uh I think it was like two to one
but remember two to one odds but
remember those guys who make the lines
want movement they want money on it I
bet by the time you guys fight you might
be a slight dog you know what I'm saying
barely but two to one this early out
slight dog
oops I think uh
um I feel like I'm gonna be more of an
underdog to be honest you think yeah I
think so I mean beavers Peter at one
point I was a four to one Underdog and
uh you know that was a Striker versus
Striker kind of match up so I do think I
think they'll probably have the uh which
I love I love that [__] I love people
getting going against me and betting
against me and thinking I'm gonna you
know go out there you know I use that
I'm on my treadmill listening to it I'll
listen to it on repeat
um so yeah it doesn't bother me but I'm
very curious you know the closer the
fight gets yeah me too but uh have you
uh did you get approached by the UFC
because they're bringing tough back so
you have Connor and Chandler so they're
trying to get big stars on them to get
the views back on that show to try to
freaking revamp that thing because it's
been a complete nightmare did no calls
for you and aljo to do that or
especially you I would assume
um no I I think I just saw didn't Dustin
Poirier say they offered him like 80 000
for six weeks yeah and he was like no
I'm good or something like that yeah I
mean I realistically for me to leave for
six weeks and do that something I would
I would want a million dollars I mean
that sounds ridiculous but there's just
if it's under that there's no shot I'm
doing that yeah no I don't sound
ridiculous I also think too I heard you
mentioned on the aerial show that you're
not getting pay-per-view points for this
fight
it kind of makes sense I mean there's an
argument where you're definitely it's
not even an argument it's a clear debate
that you're the main draw here until the
most pay-per-views but after this fight
you're going Sizzler because it's gonna
be as soon as you get the title then the
whole time pay-per-view points even
though you just renegotiated your
contract yeah
yeah yeah and I talked to him about that
like they're you know I have a very very
good relationship with the youth you've
had a lot of sit Downs face to face with
Hunter and Dana and Sean I have a very
good relation with UFC and then you pick
your pick your battles you know I wasn't
willing to die on that say you know what
I'm not fighting or I don't want it blah
blah I'm getting paid on being paid I'm
happy with what I'm being paid
pay-per-view points I I did ask I wasn't
negotiated was talked about
um but hey I'm I'm okay I'm happy with
where we're at and I know
I go out there and put Alex's lights out
which I very very well know I'm capable
of doing the next fight Pay-Per-View
points will be absolutely massive and it
will all be worth it agree brother and
also I'll get you out here soon I know
you gotta get rolling man but also you
know when I hear you're one of the few
guys I talk you you were out here we
talked before I think maybe text you're
going to negotiate your contract you
don't have you know an agent do it you
you do it yourself and usually I'm like
oh that's gonna be a nightmare worked
out for you
and then Francis ingano does the same
thing like yeah but look sugar got it
done I'm like different different and
obviously didn't it didn't really work
out in France's favor I don't know
exactly what went down in that in Dana's
office but it seems guys point to you
and go look sugar don't have an agent
like it's just different he has so much
leverage with what he brings to the
table and these other guys don't
yeah I mean anything's the day I'm a
fighter I want to fight I mean maybe
Francis doesn't really you know he's
fought he's been the champ he's done it
maybe doesn't want to fight that bad
maybe you know I want to fight I want to
fight you know I remember you know I'm
sure like every every fighter is fought
for free we've paid money just to be
able to fight and I still got that
hunger I still have that drive I still
want to fight so I was going to come do
an agreement regardless but I I will say
I'm very happy with how the deal played
out and uh you know you learn a lot
sitting down there doing doing your own
deals and it's it's it's business and
there's there's skills and levels to
business and uh yeah I had fun doing it
good for you brother
um how do you I heard you mention this
too that you in I think you said four to
five years you'd be interested in a tank
Davis a Javonte Davis fight or a Ryan
Garcia fight did you watch the uh
Javonte and Ryan fight
I did yeah yeah that I think you know
and people people hate on it but you
know people also hate it on me saying
you know I told people I was in the UFC
when I was 18. they're like what what
shut up like that's not realistic you
know so that just feels like something
like this where I say something like
that and you know get kind of shot down
but hey watch it [__] happen
you'd be weird to shut that down because
we've seen it like there's a path to
this it's not you know like when Connor
and his haters like I'm gonna fight
Floyd everyone's like dude what the and
he was the first be like dude get the
hell out of here then you see that
happen you know you got Jake and uh Nate
Diaz fighting you know you got Logan
Paul find Floyd Mayweather so it's like
when I hear that I don't go well that's
never gonna happen it's like yeah no
that's that can happen there's
definitely ways to do this you know
yeah gervante looked good too I mean the
first round against Ryan I think man
Ryan's kind of bullying he's bigger than
him and gervante made the adjustments as
a professional he is and and very very
skilled you can see he's dedicated his
life to boxing and made the adjustments
and uh you know that Ryan down finishing
with the body shot was it was a you know
beautiful performance for Javonte
um you know I'm actually a fan I do talk
[__] on him I talk [__] on a lot of
people that are under five four but that
just is what it is but he's super
skilled yes yeah he's a Facebook box
right now do you know Ryan at all have
you do are do you and Ryan Garcia have a
relationship you guys would crush it
together whatever whatever content you
create training see he's such a good
dude he lives up here man really good
dude
yeah I've messaged him or we've messed
back and forth on Instagram a few times
we haven't really ever met or shot any
content together
um but yeah that's another fight like
that could be up there eventually too
and like I said about that fight like
that fight only happens if I go out
there you know I have to at least be the
bathroom light champ potentially champ
champ
um and and Jamal has to go out there and
keep doing his thing so we both have to
be major pay-per-view stars for the UFC
to allow something like that to happen
they didn't they allowed that to happen
because Conor was as big as he was Floyd
was as big as he was and that just made
sense so if the UFC can make millions of
dollars on it they're all about it the
only way that's gonna happen is if we're
both massive pay-per-view Stars so the
stars have to align
um but yeah that that's that's something
I would be interested in for sure no I
dig it brother dream big uh are you
excited about the the Nate Diaz and uh
Jake Paul fight did you see the presser
yeah I did see the presser I'm like God
damn ideas it looks like he's a
philosopher sometimes and sometimes I'm
like God damn what the [__] did he just
say they just speak English so he's like
in between yeah there's no in between
it's either brilliant or just like is
that English like there's no it might be
the weed though I'm like maybe just too
high maybe you got a good strain or some
[__] like that maybe just too high
yeah it was interesting I like that I
think I'm I'm dude I watch every Jake
Paul Logan Paul oh and I'll watch every
day Diaz fight so the fact that Jake and
Nate are fighting I'm all about that
[__] I watched the press conference I
would be there if I wasn't you know
having to fight aljo in a couple or
getting to fight aljo a couple of weeks
later so yeah that's a fight I'm very
interested in you have a a pick on that
fight I know you're a Nate fan you're
Jake that I hate picking two because you
know Jake's my boy but you know I'm UFC
alumni so I usually always ride with the
UFC guys and with Nate I'll say this if
Nate thinks that this is just like a
YouTuber and he's gonna walk through
them and can barely train it's gonna be
a tough night for him if Nate comes in
100 and takes this serious he has the
capabilities to to beat Jake he
definitely does he's as tough as they
come and he can box his ass off this is
all predicated on Nate taking it serious
that if people tell me he's training his
ass off I would probably you know it'd
be hard for me not to bet on Nate I love
night too Jake's my guy but Nate's a dog
you know but if he's not taking it
serious it's gonna be a tough night
yeah I'm in the same boat I think the
same is it well depends on how serious
Nate takes it regardless though Nate
never really been known for being hard
to hit he's never been known for like
damn his head moving slick he's always
like holy [__] he can take a punch
correct Jake can deliver a punch and
with those boxing gloves and you wrap
your hand like a cast
you can get more power on those boxing
gloves with a right hand than you can
with the MMA gloves I think so I agree
you know we'll see we'll see Nate can
take that right hand it's at 185. Nate's
not a 185 or he's I mean why he's that
heavy but he doesn't mean he's you know
that's his that's not his fighting no
not at all agree agree so that plays a
role huge fan of both guys I've always
went for Jake and every fight and it's
like I'm not necessarily going for one
or the other just a massive fan of what
they're they're both doing and very
excited for it agree I'll get you at it
on this brother so Snoop Dogg played a
huge kind of role in your career if you
remember he was commentating when you
had that crazy knockout I would like to
see him back the way they brought the
you know the Rock in from Oswald or
something for your title fight might as
well snoopa has never said no to a job
he loves you know he's constantly
working I I don't know why we don't get
Snoop involved with this title fight in
Boston bro
yeah that's interesting I know every
time snoops mentioned my name since then
it's always been Suga Shane so we'll
have to work on that again it could be
the weed dude could be the wheat yeah
yeah yeah sugar shade I get I get it uh
yeah that's interesting well uh
I'm sure snoop's all about that you know
so that's a good idea yeah it's not a
bad idea at all uh last thing for reals
last thing uh with your GQ the GQ top 10
you had the freaking J Balvin Jay's in
there I gave you dog oh yeah yup shout
out bread and thank you bro that [__] yo
J Balvin messaged me from that yeah he's
like yo appreciate you wearing those
that was [__] that was cool
um yeah those are still some of my
favorite pair of shoes I love those so
yeah I appreciate that thank you dude
when you when you become multi-time uh
champ I wouldn't be surprised if Nike
you have a deal with Nike and you have a
very similar shoe of your own just like
that shoe was me I know J Balvin
whatever he did had his influence on it
it's like when I saw those I was like
dude that's sugar Shawn shoe bro like
you stole his body that's his [__]
yeah no yeah they've every time I wear
those people [__] like what the [__]
those are so sweet but yeah those uh you
know let's manifest that [__] would be
that [__] would be so sweet that's
happening Brother I don't even have them
I can't find a 13. when I came to him I
go those are the dopest Jays I've seen a
while I have some dope ass this new
spider versus on I would trade these in
a heartbeat for you yeah freaking J
balvin's though
yeah those are clean though those are
clean yeah the j-bell beans are hard to
beat they really are they got it they
kind of go with everything too even
though they're multi-colored they kind
of just flow with everything love it
brother well man continued success stay
healthy this uh this training camp and
you got about 15 weeks but I'm just
excited for you man you're a special
dude the UFC ninja and you're doing the
damn thing brother so thanks for coming
on
yeah appreciate it see you guys later
have a good one all right brother take
it easy brother